es ist wirklich verrückt welche rekorde
allen masc schlägt beim jungfernflug
oder besser start der falken extremen
seltsame fracht an bord die eigentlich
im weltraum gar nichts zu suchen hat ein
tesla roadster um auf dem fahrersitz
damen eine puppe in einem raumanzug
diese zieht jetzt ihre kreise durch das
sonnensystem
aber wo ist sie das werde ich immer
wieder gefragt hier der aktuelle stand
bei klicks und science fiction dienen
ihnen mars chroniken hier gibt es
täglich krasses heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und nur dann und nur dann
verpasst er keine videos herzlich
willkommen schon beim start gab es wilde
spekulationen wohin fliegt damenuhr
landet er auf dem mars oder wird er
irgendwann einmal auf die erde stürzen
oder würde jetzt ganz unspektakulär
durch den weltraum fliegen unspektakulär
ist in diesem zusammenhang vielleicht
der nicht ganz so richtige begriff mit
seinem tesla roadster als test fracht
für den erstflug der falcon heavy hat
ihnen maske die welt so richtig aus der
fassung gebracht es war übrigens sein
tesla roadster der ersten serie ein auto
im weltraum crazy und mit dabei der
hitlers geistlose galaxy die musik space
oddity von david bowie aus der
stereoanlage und natürlich einem
handtuch im handschuhfach viele grüße an
douglas adams absolut irre war es aber
wohin fliegt dieses ungewöhnliche
raumfahrzeug jetzt eigentlich von allen
masc waren bisher nur widersprüchliche
aussagen zu hören zum mars zu machst du
eben würde
und das alles scheint nicht zu stimmen
jonathan mcdowell vom harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics in
cambridge im us bundesstaat
massachusetts hat die bisher bekannten
daten analysiert und weiß wohin der
tesla unterwegs ist und also sicher
daran wird sich nichts mehr ändern der
treibstoff ist verbraucht der kurs kann
nicht mehr geändert werden
der tesla ist nach seinen berechnungen
in eine elliptische bahn rund um die
sonne eingeschränkt sowie alles was hier
so im sonnensystem durch die gegend
fliegt planeten asteroiden und jegliche
himmelskörper dabei liegt der
sonnenfenster punkt etwas außerhalb der
mars umlaufbahn
darüber haben wir ja berichtet und genau
diesen punkt hat der tester jetzt
erreicht er ist am weitesten von der
sonne entfernt und ist eben auch weiter
als der mars von uns entfernt nämlich
287 millionen kilometer
wow und das kann auch genau verfolgt
werden auf der webseite
wer ist lothar dotcom den link findet
ihr im infotext zum video damit ist der
roadster das auto das am meisten
kilometer zurückgelegt hat überhaupt 26
hat dazu eine grafik auf twitter
veröffentlicht mit der aktuellen
position text next top restaurant
patient auf die universe nächster stopp
das restaurant am ende des universums
wieder ein gruß an den autor von per
anhalter durch die galaxis douglas adams
wenn es neues zu seiner position geben
sollte oder irgendetwas schief oder
anders läuft oder er irgendwo
einschlagen sollte dann erfahre das ist
natürlich hier
denn die chancen gibt es tatsächlich mit
sechs prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit
schlägt der tesla auf der erde ein
in dem nächsten eine million jahren okay
also ganz anderes thema sehr wichtig
save your internet hashtag hier auf
youtube unbedingt das video auf klicks
um social media dazu angucken da habe
ich ein paar exklusive informationen
ja weil es ist ein wirklich absolut
wichtiges thema also abonniert hier
klicks um social media geht da auf das
video
und ich bin auf eure meinung gespannt
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran